one day Simba the Sun will set on my
time here
[Applause]
[Music]
simba who does she remind you of we all
know whose Simba's parents are and we
also know who knowledge mother is but
for some strange reason we don't know
much about her dad we've scoured the
internet looking for some answers and
found some theories that explain exactly
who knowledge dad could be keep watching
to find out who this mystery lion really
is here's the truth about knowledge
father in the Lion King get ready guys
because it's about to get weird we all
know that Simba and Nala are the biggest
power couple in the jungle but this next
theory might change the way you see them
forever it's quite clear that Mufasa is
Simba's dad but who is knowledge father
this mystery remains unknown unless you
know what clues to look for let's start
with Nala XY's unlike the rest of the
lines in the Pride nollies eyes are a
bright green color all the other lions
have amber eyes except for one yeah
we're talking about Simba's uncle's scar
need more proof studies show that female
lions prefer a darker Mane they're
actually more likely to mate with a lion
just because his mane is darker than a
lion who has a lighter mane this means
that scar was probably popular with the
lionesses at one time you know when he
was young and feisty scar he probably
fathered several cubs with many
different lionesses including knowledge
mom maybe that's why scar is so bent out
of shape that Mufasa took over the pride
lands he missed the good old days of
eating fresh zebra and hanging with the
ladies then suddenly he was stuck in a
cave with three dim-witted hyenas I'm
surrounded by this theory makes scars
behavior pretty disturbing
there was a deleted scene where he was
flirting with Nala in this scene he
declares to the rest of the pride that
he chooses Nala as his queen
so that would mean he was flirting with
his own daughter your timing couldn't be
more perfect
yeah we're not surprised that Disney
chose to cut that scene out wait if scar
is now his dad that makes Nala and Simba
first cousins
if you thought that theory was weird
well buckle up because we're going past
the cousin love Express all the way to
sibling town okay so here's what we
uncovered in a 2004 interview Lion King
directors Roger Allers and Rob Minkoff
Minkoff responded saying that after
talking a little bit about how the Lions
operate in real life prides the general
assumption was that knowledge father was
either scar or Mufasa
so apparently both scar and Mufasa can
be considered a dominant males in the
pride so it's highly likely that both of
them mated with multiple females in the
pride that means that most or all of the
Cubs on Pride Rock are actually the
children of Mufasa or scar when you
think about it there aren't any other
adult male lions on Pride Rock only
Mufasa and scar and then eventually baby
Simba
this means that Simba and Nala could be
half brother and sister to make a bad
situation worse Nala and Simba go on to
have a family together in the Lion King
to Simba's pride
seriously why didn't anyone stop this
romance from happening at the beginning
of the Lion King
Zazu tells young Simba and Nala that
their betrothed to each other that means
they were destined to be married so
everyone at Pride Rock is okay with this
brother-sister relationship yeah yeah
Pride Rock is a strange place what's
more likely than the scar or Mufasa
theory is that there was another lion
who we actually never met in the movies
ah apparently Knollys father was
mentioned in the TV series the lion
guard
according to legend and Allah's father
was born under the reign of Simba's
grandparents he and Mufasa were around
the same age legend has it that when
Nala was father was a cub he fell from a
tree but the lion guard saved him later
when he became a full-grown lion he got
together with a lioness named Sarafina
they had a young cub named you guessed
it Nala but you see nobody knows for
sure whatever became of knowledge'
father he disappeared shortly after
knowledge birth sources say that he
either met his demise in the jungle or
he simply left Pride Rock that would
mean that knowledge father abandoned her
and her mother Oh way to go dad that
would make Sarafina a single lioness mom
so in that
Anala didn't have a father growing up
and that's pretty sad still another
theory is that a different male lion
came in before Mufasa was king usually
there's only one male line who father's
all the Cubs in a pride and then when
they grow up they venture off to another
pride so they can avoid the you know
weird brother or sister cousin love
stuff we talked about earlier so maybe
there was a line from a different pride
who came in and dominated Pride Rock he
could have been responsible for
fathering a few Cubs before Mufasa was
large enough to challenge him for King
we know how much Massa likes a challenge
after all who fossa was once a young cub
just like Simba
we know that usually when a new lion
takes over a pride he does away with
another lions cubs but maybe this lion
made an exception Mufasa is strong
charismatic and powerful
maybe dollas father this mystery lion
took a liking to Mufasa
perhaps he taught me fossa everything he
knows about what it means to be king of
the jungle sure it could have been Moo
fauces father who taught him the ways of
the natural world but what if it wasn't
what if naal his father taught Mufasa
about the circle of life a lion who's
traveling from pride - pride would have
knowledge about the world around him
seriously think about all the stuff that
Mufasa tells Simba about their bodies
becoming the grass when they pass on and
that the Antelope eat the grass so
they're all locked together in this
great circle of life we are all
connected in the great circle of life
that's deep stuff and only someone who's
explored the lands could know that we
like this theory a little bit better
than the idea of every line and lioness
from Mufasa is pride being destined to
marry and have children with members of
their very own bloodline so what do you
guys think do you think that knowledge
dad was Mufasa or scar or was he from
the lion guard or was her dad a
wandering lion who rolled into the pride
lands and blew out with a breeze let us
know what you think of the comments
section below subscribe to our channel
to be the first to see our latest videos
and while you're at it give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching things
and koona Matata
[Music]